hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com
so yesterday i did a big update on amc
today is gamestop let's get into it
all right guys as usual for hours time
frame
let's see what we are having for
gamestop
so first thing as usual i like to remind
you guys
what was my last scenario so for
gamestop i was telling you that
we are having a wxy correction
which is you know a triple three a
double three you can only
just you know the both ways it just
means that you have a complex correction
that is containing zigzags flat or
triangles so here
w zigzag x zigzag
and uh y which is flat all right
i'm gonna get rid of that because you
know otherwise we don't see anything
and here guys in my last video i was
telling you that
we are doing the last wave
of this complex correction at the very
beginning i was even telling you guys
about the triangle but that didn't hold
we had
this here you know all this move that
made the difference between
a triangle that we could have had here
and here you know i still have the lower
band of my triangle
but finally we broke that so here you
know i'm not gonna go through this again
but
you could have stop loss here and boot
at this level if like you guys are
like to do some day trading but the
result is the same
is that this pattern is now finished so
what are we expecting i'm gonna tell you
very soon
what we are looking for first what you
can see guys
is i kept the lower band of my triangle
here
connecting this low and this low and
that had a good reaction here let's go
to hourly timeframe i want to show you
guys this because this is very
important you know in trading you
connect
the loads so here okay i'm going to do
it perfectly
here it's connected here almost touched
here connected and here we had this
breakout you can see guys
it's you know another surprise that
after
this move down we had this strong move
down is because here
a lot of traders saw the breakout on the
downside and probably
sold some gift stop shares you know i'm
talking here about day traders
whatever but those guys they're doing
the market so it's important to
understand
how they trade why they are doing things
so we can anticipate and here guys
after support has been broken it becomes
a resistance
so it's the same thing guys here
so bam in my last video i was telling
you that we are expecting
like here the resistance level on the
short term about still here you can see
this trend line that is still here i was
telling you we need to break this
to become bullish again and actually
complete the c wave it has been done
here guys and you can see as usual when
we have this type of breakout
it's strong moves up with a stronger
associated volume so here it worked out
perfectly
um now what you can see guys is that we
got rejected
at this level at the 165 level
roughly which is the lower band of my
previous triangle and another thing
is that here guys as you can see we
having
the 200 period moving average that is
actually hidden here
you can see bam
revealed it's hidden here guys and it's
always interesting to notice
that the lower band of my triangle is
perfectly
concerning with this 200 period moving
average
you know so this is actually our strong
resistance now we need to take it back
we will take it back
i think so because once again this
complex correction
is complete so maybe i'm missing
something but you know i don't have any
bearish alternative scenario here um
but you never know maybe the c wave is
going to be a bit longer maybe it's
going to be an abc itself you know this
can happen everything can be extended
you know there is nothing hundred
percent guaranteed but here it looks
to me very good amc looks very good as
well so those two probably gonna move
together
so it's another reason for me to confirm
my bullish case
here so guys now what we want to
happen so first let me show you
something here
like i said the 165 level is an
important level
we need to break it but another one that
we absolutely need to break
is you know this kind of pivot point
that i'm telling you about guys for very
long time
you know i put it in purple here so
everybody can see it
this one so this 173 level roughly
is very important as well when we are
above it
we are bullish when we are below it we
are bearish so for now we are still in
this complex correction
i mean for me it is complete but for
many people you know some day traders
probably
gonna keep pushing the price down at
this level the hedge funds
but if we take it back they're probably
gonna have some stop losses here so
you're gonna see that if we tread above
173
it's going to be with a strong move as
usual guys here strong move
here strong move here strong move we
don't go through this level
with a small move when we go through
this level
it is with big volume and big volatility
so something like this you know
as usual you can use idiot to kind of
predict so one
two three four five so we are waiting
for something like this to happen
so let's see if we are having it here
but
it's very important that we break this
level with
a very strong price action so and one
more thing i wanted to show you guys
so we have this level to take back the
163
you know which is the kind of 200 yeah
it's a moving level
it's going slightly higher so it's
basically going to be the same level as
the 173
on the 18th or 19th of may so we have
this one level
to take back and we have hidden enemy
guys that is actually hidden
here let me show you guys this and this
is the enemy
we really need to take back bama
okay it's hidden here guys and this is
very important that we go above that
once we did
there would be nothing technically of
course that can stop
the price going higher you still have
this 215 level but it's going to be very
weak
compared to this downward sloping trend
line that i got connecting the top of
the first wave and the top of this
first wave here as well on the lower
degree counting
so it is roughly around the 200 level
all right
so we probably gonna be rejected there
in the third wave that is probably going
to happen this week so i expect the
price action to go to 195 this week
get rejected go back to the 173
level where we're gonna have of course
some support
because if we break it guys it's gonna
become support
so bam bam bam bam
then we come back here and then of
course
we break it very strongly and this
is gonna be only guys the first
wave of my impulsive move
starting here all right and what is that
guys
what is that i'm gonna put it in yellow
this is the third wave we are waiting
for so
it is i think the very beginning of it
um so it's not gonna be like this
actually
this is only gonna be one two the three
is going to be extended here probably
four and five okay i'm expecting more
something like this and go to the 800
area i'm talking about the 800 level for
a very long time guys
let me show you once again how i get
this level
it's basic flip extensions application
but it's working very well on this kind
of market
you measure the first wave you applied
to the bottom of the second wave
eight or eight you know it depends where
you put this exactly you know
i like it to call it a hundred and
hundred is a big run number and i think
we're going there and this is only gonna
be our third wave guys
so let's see maybe then we're gonna have
four and five for those who are saying
yeah do you think 800 is the maximum
level the answer is
no guys if we go there we might go
higher i'm just saying that we're gonna
have some selling pressure here
and probably gonna have a strong
correction and then maybe we're gonna
have a fifth wave
but we're not there yet we are just
doing the third wave
and one more thing i wanted to tell you
guys
that is very important is that you know
here i'm giving you some early signals
i'm actually you know using two main
information the first is that my wxy
correction looks complete once again the
c wave can be extended
i don't think it will because i'm
looking at amc as well that gives me
very clean signals on the short term
and i'm just missing here the volumes
guys we don't have the volumes on jme
back yet so we are missing the volumes
but we're probably gonna have it when
we're gonna break
this overhead resistance of 173 and
the hidden enemy that is here guys all
right i like to put it in black because
you know you don't see it
i mean it's not a natural resistance you
know but
when you do technical analysis for a
long time you know that
this is the kind of downward sloping
trend line that is actually
very important to break so that the
bullishness
comes back in the market for good okay
guys that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to show i
see you guys